cela pourrait s'intituler l'enterrement
a souvent quatre planches et un cortège
sénatrice et député en tête le val
d'amour est venu dire son chagrin et sa
colère aussi
mais au pied du mur les élus refusent de
croire au caractère inéluctable de la
fermeture
d'abord il faudra qu'il nous prouve
qu'ils ont besoin de le fermer il faut
qu'ils nous donnent des chiffres il faut
qu'ils nous donnent leur comptabilité
au delà de ça il faut qu'ils assurent le
soutien aux 98 personnel qu'ils trouvent
une solution pour chacun d'entre eux à
l'intérieur le dialogue se noue parfois
jamais longtemps
l'ondé de choc n'est toujours pas passée
même s'ils ont apprécié le geste
la réalité est là et on sait aussi que
c'est passé de visite qui permettra de
faire une suite
dans un marché du parquet en net repli
toute solution de reprise semble
impossible et c'est l'économie de tout
un territoire qui vacille dans there ses
78 mille euros de taxe professionnelle
pour la communauté de communes
l'argent est le nerf de la guerre je
veux dire c'est au niveau ce traitement
vous avez des familles complètes le mari
et la femme qui travaillait en poney
plusieurs ils viennent d'acheter des
maisons où il faut entrer les maisons
parce que l'on dit c'est bon on est ça a
l'air de partir à l'euphorie est
toujours au lendemain des bruits ou à
l'extérieur les changes restent courtois
mais la direction internationale et
prévenu les élus réclament des garanties
on fera tout notre possible pour
accompagner les salariés les former à de
nouveaux métiers you
diop et peut-être pourquoi pas leur
offrir un poste en tchéquie je sais
c'était pas facile il ya la barrière de
la langue
la gouache une réunion est programmée
vendredi en préfecture six danseurs
ferme la france que l'on sera sa toute
dernière usine de placage bois